the treaty instituting the merger of the
european communities 8 april 1965
entered into force the governments of the
member states appointed the presidents
vice president and member of the
single commission
this appointment having been made on
1 july and our entry into
office having taken place  the fifth day
after this date it is today
July 6 that the single commission takes
office it is in this capacity that we are
gathered here my colleagues
at the time of opening the first session of
the commission of the enlarged community
I would like  above all and you
will understand it mentioned our predecessors
and k
how would I say to the new
initiatives of others to form a
really united team for your
family once again but all
best wishes
evening
are not
in fact
today